honestly if I if I hadn't known I was
getting the award I would have been
thinking who is she talking about this
wonderful person thank you so much I I
feel so much better about myself now and
about my career I am just having the
most wonderful time I don't see why we
don't do this every evening because I'm
gonna be quite upset if I don't get to
see Jennifer song who said Dawn French
again like tomorrow my mother he was
British and no longer with us sadly but
it was her favorite show and we used to
watch it together and you know I think
it made her laugh more than anything I
ever saw this award Joe means so much to
me because I grew up with Glamour
magazine and I started reading it when I
was about 12 or 13 and you have to
imagine that I was this tall when I was
12 and not very graceful and not a good
basketball player and I had a lot of
curly hair that my British mother
encouraged me to brush 100 strokes a day
which made it explode so I was like this
six foot tall troll doll and I would buy
glamour and it would have this
incredibly gorgeous all-american silky
Duty like Cheryl Tiegs on the cover and
it's really a testament to glamour that
even I in my troll doll state could read
this magazine and understand in a really
profound way that womanhood this far-off
distant country was glorious and that
women were sexy funny resourceful
powerful and that there were no limit
on what we could do and that and that I
would be okay it would all work out in
fact it would be fabulous so I want to
thank our magazine for giving me this
this thought this germ of confidence I
am sorry I have to say that it's been
such an honor and thrilled to be with
all of you tonight I really wanted to
take some scissors and cut out big holes
in my dresses because I feel like I have
too much material if my daughter were
here she would do it for me and I just
want to say I'm so actually moved to see
all of you so many different women of
all ages
you know just expressing your talents
and trusting your instincts and and
looking so beautiful why you do it and I
I've had a lot of luck in my life I've
had a lot of support and championing
from people which I'm very grateful for
I'd like to thank Joe I'd like to thank
Glamour magazine I'd certainly like to
thank the very kind readers who voted
for me or whatever they do and I would
just like to say that I'm here tonight
winning this award and this is like a
little message in a bottle to all the 12
year old girls who are reading going to
start reading this online that if I can
make it to be icon of the year you can
make it all right